let's say you wanted to solve this
equation 2 to the x squared minus 3
power is equal to 1 over the cube root
of x pause this video and see if you can
solve this well you probably realize
that this is not so easy to solve the
way that I would at least attempt to
tackle it is you would say this is 2 to
the x squared minus 3 is equal to X to
the I could rewrite this this is 1 over
X to the 1/3 so this is X to the
negative 1/3 power maybe I can simplify
it by raising both sides to the negative
3 power and so then I would get if I
raise something to an exponent then
raise that to an exponent I can just
multiply the exponents so it would be 2
to the negative 3 x squared plus 9 power
I just multiplied both of these terms
times negative 3 is equal to X to the
negative 1/3 to the negative 3 negative
1/3 times negative 3 is just 1 so that's
just going to be equal to X so it looks
a little bit simpler but still not so
easy I could try to take log base 2 of
both sides and I'd get negative 3x
squared plus 9 is equal to log base 2 of
X but once again not having an easy time
solve this and the reason why I gave you
this equation is to appreciate that some
equations are not so easy to solve
algebraically but we have other tools we
have things like computers we can graph
things and they can at least get us
really close to knowing what the
solution is and the way that we can do
that is we could say hey well what if I
had one function or one equation that
was Y is equal to 2 X 2 to the x squared
minus 3 I should say and then you had
another that was y is equal to 1 over
the cube root of x and then you could
graph each of these and then you could
see where they intersect because where
they intersect that means two to the x
squared minus three is giving you the
same y as 1 over the cube root of x or
another way to think about it is they're
going to intersect at an x value where
these two expressions are equal to each
other
so what we could do is we could go to a
graphing calculator or we could go to a
site like desmos and graph it and at
least try to approximate what the point
of intersection is and so let's do that
so I graph this ahead of time on desmos
so you can see here this is our two
sides of our equation but now we've
expressed each of them as a function
right here in blue we have two we have f
of X or I can even say this is y is
equal to f of X which is equal to 2 to
the x squared minus 3 and then in this
yellowish color I have Y is equal to G
of X which is equal to 1 over the cube
root of x and we can see where they
intersect they intersect right over
there
and we're not going to get an exact
answer but even at this level of zoom
and on the tool like desmos you can keep
zooming in in order to get a more and
more precise answer in fact you can even
scroll over this and even tell you where
they intersect but even if we're trying
to explain just looking at the graph we
can see that the x value right over here
it looks like it is happening at around
let's see this is one point five and
each of these is a tenth so this is one
point six and then it looks like it's
about two-thirds of the way to the next
one so this looks like it's about I'll
say this is approximately one point six
six and if you were to actually find the
exact solution you would actually find
this awfully close to one point six six
so the whole point here is is that even
when it's algebraically difficult to
solve something you could set up or
restate your problem or reframe your
problem in a way that makes it easier to
solve you can set this up as hey let's
make two functions and then let's graph
them and see where they intersect and
the x value where they intersect well
that would be a solution to that
equation and that's exactly what we did
right there we're saying that hey the x
value the X solution here is roughly one
point six six